Estoy seguro de que todos, absolutamente todos,
habéis visto mensajes y titulares como estos:
Amigos, Argentina tiene nuevo presidente:
el libertario Javier Milei, lo que ha provocado
reacciones de todos los colores.
Hablamos de un tipo cuya carrera ha sido meteórica:
de ser prácticamente un desconocido a convertirse
apenas unos años después en el mismísimo
presidente.
Y no un presidente cualquiera, sino uno que
llega al poder con una promesa totalmente
rupturista: cambiar por completo todo el sistema
económico, político y social de la Argentina.
Es decir, que Milei llega como una especie
de bulldozer con una misión tan clara como
ambiciosa: derribar de una vez por todas las
bases fundamentales del peronismo.
Lo mejor de todo es que Milei no solo era
un desconocido, sino que además logró esta
gesta sin pertenecer a ninguna de las históricas
formaciones políticas de la Argentina.
Lo hizo montando su propio partido, la libertad
avanza.
La cuestión es que, y tal como habéis visto,
son muchos los medios, analistas y políticos
que lo tachan de formar parte de extrema derecha.
Pero, ¿Realmente se puede decir algo así?
¿Forma parte Milei de la extrema derecha?
Y eso no es todo.
Habitualmente también se le compara con Bolsonaro,
Santiago Abascal o el propio Donald Trump.
C1 (“Muy claramente es un mini-Trump [...] Trump
es un ícono de esta nueva forma de populismo
extremo, y Milei quiere emularlo”.
Federico Finchelstein, historiador argentino
que dirige el Departamento de Historia en
la New School de Nueva York.)
Y la pregunta es, ¿Hasta qué punto se parece
Javier Milei a Donald Trump, Jair Bolsonaro
o, incluso, Santiago Abascal?
¿Realmente tiene el león argentino tantas
similitudes con el expresidente de Estados
Unidos, el expresidente de Brasil o el candidato
de Vox en España?
Desde luego, a tenor de mensajes como este,
podríamos decir que mucho:
N1 (.@realDonaldTrump es uno de los pocos
que ha entendido la batalla contra el socialismo.
Dar pelea asimilando las restricciones de
estado, las autoinflingidas y las legales
y políticas en el plano local e internacional.
Bueno, pero algunos sólo critican mirando
títulos falsos.
xD.
Javier Milei)
N7(¡Muchas gracias, Presidente @realDonaldTrump!
Su presidencia fue un ejemplo para todos los
que defendemos las ideas de la libertad y
espero conocerlo pronto.
No tenga dudas de que vamos a Hacer Argentina
Grande Otra Vez ¡VIVA LA LIBERTAD CARAJO!)
C2 (“Nuestro alineamiento de geopolítica
es Estados Unidos e Israel.
Esa es nuestra política internacional.
Nosotros no nos vamos a alinear con comunistas”
Javier Milei)
El propio Milei ha expresado muchas veces
su simpatía por todos estos actores políticos.
Y, desde luego, ellos tampoco han ocultado
la suya por el movimiento que lidera Milei.
Fijaos.
(Felicidades querido @JMilei por tu gran victoria
en las elecciones presidenciales argentinas.
Hoy se abre un camino de futuro y esperanza
para los argentinos y toda Iberoamérica que
celebramos en España con especial alegría.
¡Viva España, viva Argentina, vivan libres
de socialismo y soberanas!
Santiago Abascal en Twitter)
Sin embargo, queridos amigos no vayamos tan
de prisa.
Es verdad que podemos ver una clara coincidencia
de estilo.
Tanto Milei como Trump, Bolsonaro o Abascal
suelen tener un tono muy duro, son agresivos
y todos ellos se posicionan como una alternativa
al sistema.
En cierto modo, comparten un cierto tinte
populista: todos ellos se caracterizan por
elegir claramente a un contrincante, un enemigo;
destacar alguna medida “estrella” y casi
milagrosa que repiten hasta la saciedad y
enfrentarse a los medios de comunicación.
Desde un punto de vista de mensaje político,
los inmigrantes de Trump vienen a ser lo mismo
que la casta de Milei.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué?
Hasta aquí llegan las similitudes.
Lo cierto es que en los grandes temas, en
el posicionamiento y la agenda política,
Milei se parece tanto a Trump, Bolsonaro o
Abascal como un huevo a una castaña.
Hasta cierto punto, Trump, Bolsonaro y Abascal
sí que tienen muchos parecidos.
Sin embargo, el nuevo presidente de Argentina…
Digamos que forma parte de un club completamente
diferente.
Un momento, ¿no me creéis?
¿Pensaos que estamos exagerando?
Pues si os parece empecemos haciendo una comparación
entre Javier Milei y Donald Trump.
[Aunque en la mayoría de los casos esta misma
comparación también se podría aplicar a
Bolsonaro o Abascal]
Prestad mucha atención porque estas son las
7 grandes diferencias políticas de estos
dos líderes que, en el fondo, no podrían
ser más diferentes.
Atentos.
[Por cierto, ¿Sabéis que podéis ayudar
activamente a VisualPolitik para que sigamos
creciendo y sigamos creando contenido independiente?
¿Habéis oído hablar de nuestro boletín
semanal exclusivo para patronos?
¿O de nuestro merchandising que no están
a la venta en ningún otro sitio?
Pues si os gusta lo que hacemos y queréis
colaborar activamente con el proyecto, ya
podéis hacerlo recibiendo eso y mucho más
a cambio en la comunidad de Patreon de VisualPolitik.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.]
(EL MURO COMERCIAL)
Vale, creo que todos sabemos que este tema
es, junto con la inmigración, una de las
grandes señas de identidad del cuadragésimo
quinto presidente de los Estados Unidos de
América y también la primera gran diferencia
que podemos encontrar con Milei.
Trump es un proteccionista convencido.
Y lo mismo podríamos decir en cierto modo
de Bolsonaro y Abascal.
Estos 3 políticos suelen hablar constantemente
de hacer crecer la industria local, de comprar
productos fabricados en el país y cosas por
el estilo.
De hecho, el libre comercio es uno de los
temas que primero atrajo a Trump a la política.
Ya en la década de los 80 aparecía en programas
de televisión denunciando que Japón le estaba
robando a Estados Unidos con sus exportaciones.
Por eso, cuando en 2015 anunció su candidatura
a las primarias republicanas, puso, precisamente,
al comercio en el centro de su campaña.
C3 (“China nos está matando [...] El dinero
que sacaron de Estados Unidos es el mayor
robo en la historia de nuestro país”.
Donald Trump en 2015)
Y cuando llegó al gobierno…
Bueno, digamos que no se quedó precisamente
quieto.
Trump lanzó una guerra comercial contra la
Unión Europea.
Sacó a Estados Unidos del TPP, el mayor acuerdo
de libre comercio de la historia.
Lanzo una gran guerra comercial contra China,
imponiendo montones de aranceles.
Y amenazó a diestro y siniestro con tomar
represalias comerciales.
[Al final el resultado de todas estas medidas
fue un fracaso.
El déficit comercial siguió aumentando y
según varios estudios, la guerra comercial
le costó decenas de miles de millones de
dólares a las familias norteamericanas y
destruyó más de 200 mil empleos.
Pero eso es otra historia.]
Y, vale, puede que alguno esté pensando…
Eso lo hizo por esto y por aquello, pero realmente
no es que estuviera en contra del libre comercio.
¿A no?
Pues ahora Trump se ha vuelto a presentar
a las primarias republicanas.
Y, ¿sabéis cuál es una de sus medidas estrellas?
Pues…
C4 (“Trump promete nuevos aranceles masivos
si es elegido, arriesgándose a una guerra
económica mundial”.
Washington Post)
Vale, seguro, seguro que alguno de vosotros
está pensando…
Alaaa, ya está la prensa manipulando otra
vez.
Pues fijaos en lo que dice él mismo.
C5 (“Creo que, cuando las empresas entran
y vierten sus productos en los Estados Unidos,
deberían pagar automáticamente, digamos,
un impuesto del 10%".
Donald Trump)
Exacto.
Hablamos de que Trump está defendiendo un
arancel general a cualquier producto que entre
en Estados Unidos del 10%.
Para que os hagáis una idea, eso supondría
más que triplicar el arancel medio que actualmente
está por debajo del 3%.
Y la pregunta es, ¿qué dice Milei sobre
este tema?
Pues básicamente todo lo contrario.
Milei quiere abrir las fronteras argentinas
al comercio internacional.
De hecho, en su programa de gobierno se ha
comprometido a eliminar aranceles y cualquier
otra restricción al comercio internacional,
incluyendo cupos, permisos y autorizaciones.
Incluso, sobre el Mercosur ha llegado a decir
cosas como estas:
Yo creo que hay que
eliminar el Mercosur porque es una Unión
aduanera defectuosa que perjudica a los
argentinos de bien o sea es en el fondo
es un comercio administrado por Estados
para favorecer empresarios prebendarios)
Así que ya lo veis, primera gran diferencia.
Sigamos.
(¡CERRAD EL BANCO CENTRAL!)
Queridos amigos, si antes decíamos que el
proteccionismo era toda una seña de identidad
del trumpismo, creo que nadie tendrá la menor
duda de que la eliminación del banco central
para que los políticos no puedan meter mano
en él es uno de los grandes rasgos políticos
de Milei.
De hecho, el nuevo presidente argentino hizo
de la dolarización y el cierre del banco
central su política estrella.
Fue algo que defendió vehemente, ¡Vaya,
si lo hizo!
Milei culpa al banco central muchos de los
grandes males de la economía argentina, empezando
por la inflación.
Bueno, mejor dicho, culpa la capacidad de
los políticos de utilizar el banco central
para mangonear, financiar todos sus caprichos
y monetizar la deuda pública.
Según Milei eso ha destrozado el peso y las
finanzas argentinas.
Pues bien, ¿sabéis qué?
Trump defiende básicamente…
Lo contrario.
Sí, sí, me habéis oído bien.
Una de las grandes y constantes críticas
de Trump durante su etapa en la Casa Blanca
fue precisamente la independencia de la Reserva
Federal.
Trump intentó constantemente presionarles
para que imprimieran más dinero, bajarán
los tipos e, incluso, monetizaran la deuda
federal.
C6 ("La Reserva Federal debería reducir nuestras
tasas de interés a CERO, o menos, y luego
deberíamos comenzar a refinanciar nuestra
deuda" Donald Trump en 2019)
C7 (“Sabemos que hice mucha presión [...] Fue
una presión externa, porque nadie sabe si
realmente puedes hacer eso o no, pero lo hice
porque pensé que sus tipos de interés eran
demasiado altos.
Y finalmente bajaron sus tipos de interés.
Donald Trump)
Y, ojo, que los tipos llegaron a un máximo
del 2,5% mientras la economía norteamericana
crecía a buen ritmo…
Y, aun así, Trump se quejaba y presionaba
a la Reserva Federal una y otra vez.
¿Entendéis ahora cómo se empezó a cocinar
la crisis de inflación?
El caso, es que expresidente lo hizo durante
su tiempo en la Casa Blanca y lo vuelve a
hacer ahora otra vez como candidato en las
primarias republicanas.
N3 (15 sep 2023: Trump se lamenta de las altas
tasas de interés e indica que podría presionar
a la Reserva Federal para que bajen.
CNBC)
¿Independencia del banco central?
¡Ja!
Impriman más dinero…
Ese era uno de los grandes caballos de batalla
de Trump, porque sabía que a corto plazo
eso estimularía la economía, lo que mejoraría
su nivel de popularidad.
Ojo, no lo decimos nosotros, lo decía el
mismo.
C8 (“La gente no puede comprar casas.
No pueden hacer nada.
Quiero decir, no pueden pedir dinero prestado.
Donald Trump)
Insisto hablamos de tipos en el entorno del
2%.
Y la cuestión es que te parezca mejor o peor,
la opinión de Milei en esto es exactamente
la contraria: nada de imprimir más dinero,
nada de inflar artificialmente la economía
nacional y nada de monetizar deuda pública.
Otra diferencia importante, ¿no os parece?
Claro que no hemos terminado.
De hecho, el empeño de Trump con que la Reserva
Federal expandiera la oferta monetaria tiene
mucho que ver con los siguientes 2 puntos.
¡Atentos!
T(3.
¡MÁS MADERA!)
Vale, tanto Trump como Milei, y también Bolsonaro
y Abascal, hablan de bajar impuestos.
Eso a priori puede ser un punto en común…
Sin embargo, se apoya en una diferencia fundamental.
Milei quiere bajar impuestos, compensando
la caída de los ingresos públicos con recortes
de gasto.
En el caso de Trump…
Eso no es así.
Trump quería que la Reserva Federal bajase
los tipos, imprimiera más dinero y comprará
más deuda pública, precisamente, para financiar
su creciente déficit.
De hecho, el crecimiento del déficit anual
se sitúa como el mayor aumento en relación
al tamaño de la economía de todos los presidentes
de la historia de Estados Unidos.
Solo le adelantan George Washington y Abraham
Lincoln con una diferencia: Trump no tuvo
que hacer frente a guerras dentro del país.
Digamos que el expresidente norteamericano
hizo crecer año tras año el gasto público
mientras, además, bajaba impuestos.
El boquete presupuestario fue enorme.
Para que os hagáis una idea, cuando llegó
a la Casa Blanca el déficit era del 2,5%
y en 2019 el déficit público alcanzó ya
el 4,6% pese a que el país crecía y aún
no había llegado la pandemia.
Otra diferencia importante, porque para Milei
el déficit cero y reducir el gasto público
es una prioridad.
Y luego, para colmo, amigos…
Llegó la pandemia.
T(4.
LA MONTAÑA)
Por la montaña no nos referimos a las rocosas
ni nada por el estilo, sino a la enorme montaña
de deuda que siguió acumulando Donald Trump.
Durante apenas 4 años de gobierno, la deuda
pública creció en casi 7,8 billones de dólares.
Más de 20 mil dólares por habitante.
¡Una locura!
Y no solo eso, cuando llegó la pandemia,
Trump mostró claramente cómo defendía enfrentarse
a una crisis:
Gastando toneladas y toneladas de dinero público.
Incluso, llegó a enviar cheques a las familias
para que se lo gastaran.
De hecho, la respuesta del gobierno federal
solo a la crisis de la Covid siguiendo el
plan de Trump superó el 8% del PIB.
Por comparar, entre 1933 y 1939 el gasto federal
creció bajo el New Deal de Roosevelt creció
en aproximadamente un 5% del PIB.
Y la respuesta a la gran recesión del 2008
equivalió a un 3%.
¿El resultado del plan de Trump?
Una deuda pública disparada o, mejor dicho,
aún más disparada.
Insisto esto es algo que te puede gustar más
o menos, valorar estas medidas no es la intención
de este vídeo.
La cuestión es que de nuevo va en dirección
contraria a lo que defiende Milei.
Además, cómo Trump tenía que financiar
ese enorme boquete presupuestario…
Entonces presionaba a la Reserva Federal para
que bajara tipos y comprara deuda pública.
En este aspecto, la posición de Trump era
más parecida a la de Sergio Massa que a la
de Javier Milei.
Así que ni en lo que se refiere al banco
central, ni a la forma de bajar impuestos,
ni al nivel de gasto público ni en lo que
se referiere a la deuda pública, ni tampoco
al comercio internacional, Milei y Trump tienen
posiciones compartidas.
Más bien como veis están en las antípodas.
Claro que no todo es la economía.
T(5.
EL ABORTO)
Milei lo tiene muy claro y no se corta un
pelo: dice que el aborto es un asesinato y
está furiosamente en contra.
Incluso ha prometido un referéndum para dar
marcha atrás a la legalización que se aprobó
en Argentina en 2020.
(“Estoy en contra del aborto, abiertamente,
porque va en contra del derecho a la vida”.
Javier Milei)
El nuevo presidente argentino ha llegado a
decir que las personas que están a favor
del aborto tienen y cito literalmente “el
cerebro lavado por una política asesina”.
¿Y Donald Trump?
Bueno, digamos que no tiene una posición
tan clara ni tampoco es algo prioritario para
él.
En 1999, por ejemplo, defendió públicamente
el derecho a decidir de las mujeres.
Es decir, una posición muy similar a la que,
por ejemplo, tiene Joe Biden.
Es verdad que luego se jacta de que bajo su
gobierno se escogieron a jueces conservadores
para el supremo y que eso hizo caer la conocida
doctrina de Roe contra Wade de 1973, que reconocía
el derecho de la mujer a abortar, lo que ha
trasladado la cuestión a la política estatal.
Pero lo hace porque sabe que no puede renunciar
al apoyo de muchos sectores conservadores.
Pero eso sí, al mismo tiempo Trump rechaza
apoyar una restricción nacional y de hecho
ahora en campaña podemos encontrar mensajes
como este:
N4 (Trump llama a la prohibición del aborto
de DeSantis "un terrible error", lo que ha
provocado la ira de algunos republicanos clave.
AP)
A lo que DeSantis no dudo en responder:
C10 ("No sé cómo puedes siquiera hacer la
afirmación de que eres pro-vida si estás
criticando a los estados por promulgar protecciones
para los bebés que tienen latidos del corazón",
Ron DeSantis)
Así que, ya lo veis, otro tema donde Milei
y Trump juegan en ligas diferentes.
Pero…
Sigamos.
T(6.
¡QUE NO PASEN!)
Vale, si antes decíamos que el proteccionismo
era una de las señas de identidad del trumpismo,
creo que todos coincidiremos en que la inmigración
es la otra gran característica.
Trump no quiere inmigrantes…
De ningún tipo.
Defiende acabar con la inmigración ilegal,
pero también restringir y limitar la inmigración
legal.
De hecho, la forma de hablar que tiene hacia
las personas que llegan del extranjero no
es precisamente muy acogedora.
Y, de hecho, su candidatura para 2025 pasa
precisamente por eso: por restringir aún
más la inmigración tanto ilegal como legal.
Por supuesto, habla de deportar a millones
de personas.
La posición de Javier Milei, en cambio, es,
otra vez, muy diferente.
De entrada es conceptual e ideológicamente
partidario de sistemas de inmigración mucho
más abiertos.
En su opinión, el único problema que tiene
la inmigración es el coste que tiene para
los servicios sociales.
C11 (“Hay documentos que prueban que aquellos
países que son más abiertos, tienen mayor
innovación, crecen más, con lo cual la inmigración
es algo bueno [...] Cuando vinieron nuestros
abuelos o nuestros padres.
Vinieron a ganarse el pan con el sudor de
la frente y no había estado de bienestar.
El problema arranca con la inmigración cuando
hay estado de bienestar" Javier Milei)
Por eso ha dicho que si existiera por ejemplo
un sistema de Váucheres generalizados o un
sistema privado, entonces apoyaría prácticamente
un régimen de inmigración abierta.
Otra vez es una posición que está en las
antípodas de Trump.
Pero, queridos amigos, aún nos queda un último
punto.
T(7.
UCRANIA Y TIRANOS VARIOS)
A veces Milei ha dicho que apoya la visión
exterior de Trump…
Sin embargo, cuando entramos en los detalles
la cosa cambia bastante:
C12 ("Aquellos que defendemos sin titubeos
un modelo de Sociedad Abierta y Libre debemos
unir fuerzas en favor de una estrategia efectiva
para enfrentar a los enemigos de la Libertad
que como en el pasado, vuelven a intentar
arrastrar a la humanidad a tiempos oscuros
de caos y miseria".
Javier Milei)
Esto hace que Milei apoye a Ucrania y a Israel,
mientras que Trump apuesta por parar la ayuda
a Kyiv.
Y eso por no hablar de encuentros como este.
Seguro, seguro que todos lo recordáis, ¿verdad?
(Trump dice que norcoreano Kim "es muy honorable".
Voz de América)
¿Y qué dice Milei?
Pues básicamente que con los autoritarismos
y el comunismo no quiere saber absolutamente
nada.
Que a nivel de comercio privado muy bien,
pero a nivel de gobierno, nada de nada.
(“Yo no promovería la relación con comunistas,
ni con Cuba, ni con Venezuela, ni con Corea
del Norte, ni con Nicaragua, ni con China”)
Así que ya lo veis.
Estas son 7 de las grandes diferencias que
existen entre Trump y Milei.
Y también entre Milei y Bolsonaro y Abascal.
Y ojo, que como veis, no hablamos, precisamente,
de asuntos precisamente pequeños o intrascendentes,
sino de cuestiones absolutamente claves.
Pilares fundamentales a la hora de dar forma
al tipo de estado que defienden unos y otros.
Vale, es verdad.
Milei y Trump también tienen alguna coincidencia
en asuntos como el cambio climático, las
armas o las regulaciones del gobierno.
Sin embargo, ya lo habéis visto, defienden
modelos de sociedad completamente diferentes.
Y luego, te guste más o te guste menos este
personaje y las políticas que defiende lo
de que forme parte de la extrema derecha que
defienden muchos periodistas…
Pues bueno, ¿Qué queréis qué os diga?
Ni por asomo.
Milei ha prometido recortar el gasto público,
abrir las fronteras, bajar los impuestos y
cerrar el banco central.
Defiende y promueve la libertad y no tiene
ningún problema por cuestión de género,
procedencia o sexualidad.
Así que la verdad…
¿Qué tiende de extrema derecha?
En todo caso podremos decir que es ultraliberal,
libertario o ultra-capitalista…
Pero seamos honestos, cuado hablamos de extrema
derecha pensamos en algo muy distinto.
Sea como sea, la pregunta ahora es, ¿lo conseguirá?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios